- [Instructor] What we have here
is a graph of y is equal to f of x,
and these numbers are the
areas of these shaded regions,
these regions between
our curve and the x-axis.
What we're going to do in
this video is do some examples
of evaluating definite
integrals using this information
and some knowledge of
definite integral properties.
So let's start with an example.
Let's say we want to evaluate
the definite integral
going from negative four
to negative two of f of x
d of x plus the definite
integral going from
negative two to zero of f of x dx.
Pause this video, and see if you can
evaluate this entire expression.
So this first part of our expression,
the definite integral from negative four
to negative two of f of x dx,
we're going from x equals negative four
to x equals negative two.
And so this would evaluate as
this area
between our curve and our x-axis,
but it would be the negative of that area
because our curve is below the x-axis.
And we could try to estimate it
based on the information they've given us,
but they haven't given
us exactly that value.
But we also need to figure
out this right over here.
And here we're going from x
equals negative two to zero
of f of x d of x, so that's
going to be this area.
So if you're looking at the sum of these
two definite integrals, and
notice the upper bound here
is the lower bound here,
you're really thinking about,
this is really going to
be the same thing as,
this is equal to the definite integral
going from x equals negative four
all the way to x equals zero of f of x dx.
And this is indeed one of
our integration properties.
If our upper bound here is the
same as our lower bound here
and we are integrating the same thing,
well, then you can merge these two
definite integrals in this way.
And this is just going
to be this entire area.
But because we are below the x-axis
and above our curve here,
it would be the negative of that area.
So this is going to be
equal to negative seven.
Let's do another example.
Let's say someone were to ask you,
walk up you on the street and say, quick,
here's a graph, what is
the value of the expression
that I'm about to write down,
the definite integral going
from zero to four of f of x dx
plus the definite integral
going from four to six
of f of x dx?
Pause this video, and see
if you can figure that out.
Well, once again, this
first part right over here,
going from zero to four,
so what would be is it would be this area.
It would be this five right over here,
but then we would need
to subtract this area
because this area is below our
x-axis and above our curve.
We don't know exactly what this is.
But luckily we also need,
we need to take the sum of
everything I just showed,
but plus,
plus this right over here.
And this, we're going from four to six,
so it's going to be this area.
Well, once again, when
you look at it this way,
you can see that this expression
is going to be equivalent to
taking the definite integral
all the way from zero to six,
zero to six of f of x dx.
And once again, even if
you didn't see the graph,
you would know that
because, in both cases,
you're getting the definite
integral of f of x dx.
And our upper bound here
is our lower bound here.
So once again, we're able
to merge the integrals.
And what is this going to be equal to?
Well, we have this area
here, which is five.
And then we have this area, which is six.
That was given to us.
But since it's below the
x-axis and above our curve,
when we evaluate it as
a definite integral,
it would evaluate as a negative six.
So this is going to be
five plus negative six,
which is equal to negative one.
And we're done.